[tense music]
WELL, WELL, WELL...
JACK, WELCOME.
MAKE YOURSELF COMFORTABLE.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE HERE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
- YOU'LL NEVER GET AWAY
WITH THIS, DRAVIC.
[spits]
- THAT IS ALL, DAQUAN.
LEAVE US.
♪ ♪
NOW, WHERE WERE WE, THEN?
- [chuckles]
YOU'RE WASTING
YOUR TIME, DRAVIC.
THE MILITARY CODES
WERE DESTROYED.
- IS THAT SO?
I THINK YOU'RE BLUFFING, JACK,
AND I AM ABOUT TO CALL...
YOUR BLUFF.
YOU SEE, JACK,
I AM A PLAYER IN THIS GAME.
BUT...
[chuckles]
I'M ALSO THE DEALER.
I HOLD ALL OF THE CARDS.
[door rattles]
[sighs, clears throat]
[chuckles]
YOU SEE, JACK,
IF I WERE TO GO ALL-IN,
YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO COVER THE BET.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- I WAS THINKING, LIKE,
MAYBE I COULD BE, LIKE,
YOUR TORTURING ASSISTANT
OR SOMETHING?
I COULD BE
IN THE ROOM WITH YOU
AND BE THAT GUY
THAT STANDS IN THE BACKGROUND
ALL INTIMIDATING-LIKE.
AND THAT WAY--
- FINE, FINE.
OVER THERE,
AND KEEP YOUR TRAP SHUT.
- YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I--
THAT'S WHAT I WAS THINKING.
- [chuckles]
- ARE YOU TWO DONE
WITH YOUR LITTLE LADIES' CHAT?
- OH!
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID THAT.
- YOU KNOW, JACK, IT'S VERY
APROPOS THAT YOU WOULD SAY THAT,
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
WE SHOULD HAVE A CHAT.
AND WHEN I SAY "WE,"
I MEAN JUST YOU AND ME.
ARE YOU A CHESS PLAYER, JACK?
- SURE.
- SO THEN YOU ARE AWARE
THAT EACH PIECE
SERVES A DIFFERENT FUNCTION.
[plastic crinkling]
YOU S--
[crinkling stops]
WHEREAS YOU ARE
MERELY A PAWN,
YOU SEE, JACK, I AM A QUEEN.
[plastic crinkling]
[crinkling stops]
I AM ALLOWED TO MOVE
AROUND THE BOARD WITH IMPUNITY.
[plastic crinkling]
WHAT IS WITH THE LOLLIPOP?
- YO, MAN, I WAS THINKING, LIKE,
MAYBE DURING YOUR CHESS SPEECH,
YOU COULD SUCK
ON THIS LOLLIPOP,
'CAUSE THEN
THAT SHOWS HIM, LIKE,
YOU SO COMFORTABLE
WITH TORTURE,
YOU JUST DO SOMETHING STUPID
LIKE SUCKING ON A LOLLIPOP.
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
[thud]
- I NEED YOU TO GO
OVER THERE RIGHT NOW.
I NEED YOU TO BE STILL.
OKAY?
- OR--
- NO.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
NO "OR" INVOLVED.
GO OVER THERE.
- OKAY.
YOU SHOULDN'T CALL YOURSELF
A QUEEN, THOUGH,
'CAUSE WHERE I'M FROM,
THAT MEANS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT--
- SHH.
[breathes deeply]
JACK...
I'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR THIS MOMENT
FOR A VERY, VERY LONG TIME.
I WANTED TO MAKE
AN INTRODUCTION
TO YOUR NEW BEST FRIEND.
[laughs evilly]
- I'LL NEVER TALK.
- OH, THIS WILL MAKE
YOU TALK, JACK.
- PLUS, YOU DON'T EVEN
NEED TO STAB HIM AT FIRST.
YOU COULD JUST, LIKE, CARESS
HIS CHEEK WITH THE BLADE--
SOMETHING JUST REAL,
LIKE, CRAZY.
- YEAH, I GOT IT. I GOT IT.
- YEAH, YOU GOOD.
- THAT'S WHAT
I WAS PLANNING ON DOING.
I'M SORRY.
WHERE DID WE FIND YOU?
- SHAQUAN'S COUSIN.
- WHO IS SHAQUAN?
- SHAQUAN.
- NO, NO.
I'M ASKING YOU WHO HE IS.
- HE GOT KICKED INTO SOME LAVA,
SO THAT'S WHEN I CAME IN.
- OKAY.
THAT'S WONDERFUL.
I NEED YOU TO GO OVER THERE,
AND I NEED YOU TO BE
STOCK-STILL,
LIKE A STATUE.
- AH, YEAH, YEAH.
- NOW.
LIKE, YOU NEED TO
KEEP MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION.
- NO.
YEAH, I'M GOOD.
- [sighs]
JACK...
THE MILITARY CODES ARE NOT EVEN
THE PRIMARY REASON
WHY YOU ARE HERE.
I WANTED YOU ALL TO MYSELF.
HE'S STANDING BACK THERE
LIKE AN ACTUAL STATUE, ISN'T HE?
- YEAH, IT'S WEIRD.
- GOD DAMN HIM.
DAQUAN, YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAND
LIKE AN ACTUAL STATUE--
NOT LITERALLY.
I DIDN'T MEAN IT LITERALLY.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT SOUNDED STUPID
WHEN YOU SAID THAT ORIGINALLY.
- YEAH, IT WOULD BE STUPID
FOR A PERSON
TO DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
- SHOOT, 'CAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW.
I WAS LIKE, "WHAT?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE"--
- OKAY.
JACK...
TODAY YOU WILL EXPERIENCE
THE MOST EXQUISITE PAIN.
I MAY OR MAY NOT--
- OH! YO!
WE GOT PICTURES
OF HIS GIRLFRIEND.
- UH-HUH.
- THAT'S IT.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH TORTURE
OVER RIGHT THERE.
YOU COULD JUST SHOW HIM PICTURES
OF HIS GIRLFRIEND,
AND HE'LL DO WHATEVER YOU SAY.
THERE IT IS.
OH!
YOU KNOW WHAT?
EVEN BETTER--WE GOT A CAGE.
IT'S GOT A HOLE AT THE BOTTOM,
SO YOU COULD PUT THAT
OVER HIS HEAD.
AND THIS OTHER HOLE--
YOU COULD PUT, LIKE,
A RAT OR A SCORPION
UP IN THERE.
- THAT'S WHAT IT'S THERE FOR,
DAQUAN, ALL RIGHT?
THAT IS WHAT IT IS THERE FOR
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
ALL OF THE IMPLEMENTS THAT
YOU'RE SEEING ON THE TABLE THERE
ARE THERE
FOR A PARTICULAR REASON!
- WHAT ABOUT THAT?
- OH!
YOU KNOW WHAT?
DAQUAN, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO BE INVOLVED?
- THAT'S WHAT I WAS THINKING
SINCE THE BEGINNING.
[tense music]
I WAS THINKING...
MAYBE YOU SHOULD JUST TELL HIM,
LIKE, THE MILITARY CODES.